Encuentra el volumen del cubo
cuyas aristas miden 8xy cuadrada.
Aquí tenemos un cubo
y nos están diciendo que sus aristas...
y en el cubo, todas las aristas tienen la misma longitud, cada una de ellas mide 8xy cuadrada,
así que la longitud de esta arista
que podemos llamar el ancho,
mide 8xy cuadrada,
la longitud de esta arista,
que podemos llamar la profundidad o el largo
sería de 8xy cuadrada,
y finalmente la altura
de esta arista que tenemos aquí,
también mide 8xy cuadrada.
En un cubo todas las aristas son iguales,
ahora para calcular el volumen de cualquier
prisma rectangular multiplicas estas dimensiones,
multiplicas el ancho, por la profundidad, por la altura, ahora como dijimos en el cubo miden igual.
Puedes tomar esta dimensión
y multiplicarla por sí misma 3 veces,
o puedes elevarla a la tercera potencia.
Así es que el volumen del cubo,
lo podemos calcular como
8xy cuadrada,
y podría multiplicar esto por si mismo 3 veces,
o lo que es lo mismo lo elevamos a la tercera potencia
y es por eso que elevar a la tercera potencia
se dice elevar al cubo, pues es como si estuvieras calculando el volumen de un cubo,
cuya dimensión
es lo que estás elevando a la tercera potencia.
Y esto ¿a cuánto va a ser?
Bueno cuando tomas un producto
y estás elevando eso a una potencia,
eso es lo mismo que eleves a la potencia cada uno de los factores, y posteriormente realices el producto,
así es que esto equivale a 8 al cubo,
por "x" al cubo o "x" a la tercera potencia,
y eso que multiplica a "y" cuadrada
elevada al cubo,
o elevada a la tercera potencia.
Y ¿esto cuánto nos da?
Bueno 8 al cubo, 8 por 8, 64
y 64 por 8...
vamos a hacerlo por aquí...
64 por 8, 8 por 4 = 32 llevamos 3,
6 por 8 = 48 y 3 = 51
512, esto es igual a 512,
multiplicado por "x" cúbica...
"x" cúbica...
y multiplicada por "y" cuadrada al cubo,
aquí vamos a aplicar la regla
del producto de los exponentes.
Esto va a ser "y" elevado a la potencia 2 por 3
ó "y" a la sexta.
Hemos concluido, encontramos que el volumen
del cubo es 512x cúbica "y" a la sexta.